you ought to get us you ought to put
this in put this in would be some
lowdown [ __ ] you just try to get this
[ __ ] through customs West Coast Customs
my guy and coming through the back now
huh I can't Lee I need a key car you
know what's going on with this is a
shacks Mercedes I built him about two
almost three years ago the diesel shirt
and the big diesel it was going on so
come to shirt and good only ass class
convertible for suicide doors so tell me
what you actually did I know we cut the
roof off of it
convertible top boom and then we
suicided the door for the Benz
yeah get on in the back right there El
Presidente Hey Baby how you doing I'm
sense this is Shaq old car mom saying
well hop in baby
reach over you know what's funny is the
reason this even came about was he saw
something on the internet somebody made
a concept really no big called me up
he's like yo I bet you can't make this
s-class and convertible I'm like did you
forget who you called he's like I bet
you can't do it a couple years later
here it is he's over it wants to sell it
he's over it yeah he gave yeah I'm bill
your act like 40 something cars so it's
always like he's bored of it sell it get
me this so you made the car it was a bit
Shaq saw it
Shaq's richest [ __ ] he's over it now you
want to sell it cuz you're over it so
you saying like any ordinary Joe anybody
can walk in anybody can come in and get
this car yes sir
now keep in mind you have people
watching willing and wanting to have an
opportunity to buy this car this is your
chance
how much will you sell this car for turn
take it out
bring me that briefcase hey listen man
250,000 ain't bad man I've y'all tested
have y'all put it on Sunset Boulevard
I've y'all just know Sam went around the
strip it's probably pull away okay yeah
has been everywhere or as soon as I
finish that big was in it everywhere
true yeah all right cool we got a couple
little things
that's what do you ever what the hell is
this brother this would like it looks
like a hearse how come I knew you were
thinking that I really should get one of
those I'm killing the game no no no so
you put some Chanel that's nice thinking
oh man that's just nice this is a fan's
ago it's the dancing it's um it's some
pearls enough I knew you're gonna get
distracted on our way to what I was
showing you I'm a kid in the candy store
you know that what you got now man
so remember gone is 60 seconds of movie
yeah [ __ ] let's change you know so
there is a replica of that car remember
that car yeah this is one of the most
expensive Mustangs to be built
this right here this car is reading bro
I love the paint I love the details I
love the rally stripes my god you like
you can eat off this car I did that that
is so nice this is going to Dubai you're
sending this to Dubai yeah
so I'm sitting in there before him and
he's gonna see this probably before he
gets it probably says [ __ ] tell him
he can have you I just feel like this is
one of the original muscle car yeah made
with real steel made real steel you get
hit this car yeah yes
one car be messed up and other them to
go home that's one of those things at
that but you can feel the car actually
has personality when you get in this car
man it's like this car was Swiss cheese
when we stripped down the pain love to
see you know seeing it all come together
is pretty crazy and just the amount of
work that the guys put into this you
know details I mean the paint on this
car is probably one of the nicest paint
job it was very nice I'm sorry
Wow I mean I can't believe that that
Mustang really my kind of vehicle
American Muscle a few hundred thousand
dollars really something that I would
consider having him feel for me myself
personally now the beans the shag beans
the shack concept car is definitely for
sale you you can have the opportunity to
own this vehicle you can purchase it for
quarter million dollars two hundred
fifty thousand dollars do you will you
consider again Shaq's concept car how
eleven